we're not giving people American Express
cards we are giving them a food card
let's go back to Eric Adams because as
you know he created a as if New York
City doesn't have enough problem and
hasn't has enough of their tax base
disappear he found a cool 53 million uh
so that he could give credit cards to
illegals I maybe we could all take a
trip to New York City after and pretend
we're illegals and get some cash let's
see we're not giving people American
Express cards we are giving them a food
card so instead of a debit card instead
of having to deliver food and have
people eat food that we were seeing
waste in food they're now able to get
their own food I mean I don't even know
what he's talking about and trust me
there's a longer version of it I didn't
want to budgeon you with it you are
giving you are taking money from your
legal taxpayer base which again it's
thinning out because everyone's leaving
New York and then you are giving it to
illegals so that how about you just say
to the illegals you can't stay here but
we know you're tolerant and you're
diverse and you're full of chocolate so
you want as many of these people as
possible and you want to do it on the
backs of your actual
citizens